[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's
Friday night yep and it's Tom is back
yeah I'm back and back ladies and
gentlemen yeah we're going to the club
tonight we're just going to do a couple
we're going to like two hours with y'all
brought some video and everything to
share and everything from the trip from
the Expedition the Expedition yeah went
back to Mississippi yeah went to Laurel
Mississippi that's how it goes y uh yeah
everyone's giving their condolences oh
yeah yeah well you know um it was no
surprise I knew my dad was going I mean
this has been this has been going on for
years um his that triple bypass surgery
bought him about five or six years the
last two of it wasn't too good but but
it did buy him some time and and
uh overall you know what I mean he
didn't like it he couldn't do what he
wanted to do so uh I was with him when
he died he was asleep died in
asleep and uh because they basically put
him under and uh you know died
peacefully he [__] entered the
[__] Realm of the the another world
of the
force and so he could recycle enter the
ploma yeah cuz he couldn't move forward
in in in that body it was all [__] up
he had all kinds of problems yeah I mean
he had lung cancer he had di diabetes he
had a triple bypass bad heart yeah he
um [__] he missing most of his teeth
because of the
diabetes his right foot was swelled up
and he got sepsis and pneumonia oh yeah
that too I it was just overwhelming him
and it was and his it was just because
his blood pressure was so [__] low
because his his heart started to fail
from congestive heart failure yeah so
it's just it was like six things at
once and so there was no way out of it I
mean they treated him and [__] and after
a few days they're like the only thing
keeping him alive is this heart medicine
his blood pressure medicine and the
longer we keep him on this the more his
heart becomes congested yeah so we're
like so we want to know what it is you
want to do we let him go they said okay
I mean he was saying that too yeah he
was saying let me die yeah he wasn't
saying that when we were around he was
he was putting on a yeah he didn't want
us he didn't want us to hear that he was
telling the he was telling the the
nurses let me let me
die and then my grandma was doing that
too toward the end and uh so he's like
uh the only thing was keeping alive was
that blood pressure medicine so they cut
meds on him and then just started
hitting him every every two hours of
pretty healthy Wallop of
morphine he uh so I went in there you
know they called us they called us back
this was in the middle of the night
round well it yeah cuz I was on like I
was on FaceTime with you and then Scott
came and knocked on your on door and I
was like we got to go to the hospital
and you were like okay I'll you I went
is he dead and they said no but he's
he's going and I said okay so
um got back there and they told us what
the deal was is that he wasn't going to
make it so
uh they uh pulled treatment on him
started flooding him with morphine
but when we showed up there you know we
didn't talk to him we didn't say
anything about death or anything we told
him he was getting better he like man
the numbers are looking good you know as
we lied the whole
way well you know didn't want to upset
him he knew though he knew yeah and the
thing about it is that like you went
through the whole thing you know when he
was there for the bypass yeah and like I
said he got a little bit of Hospital
psychosis he was thinking of shooting
his way out of the hospital cuz he
thought he been kidnapped so it's like
so they're kind of just trying to keep
him calm you know they had him tied down
they didn't want to panic yeah they had
him tied down his knuckles were all
purple when he was punching the side of
the bed and [__] pulling he was a
handful yeah he was he was fighting and
um so uh I said uh yeah they uh they
said you're kind of uncomfortable right
now he showed up it was dark see they
had the [__] Hospital lights yeah cuz
he sent me the video I'm like oh man
it's so dark it dark in there because it
was because it was nighttime lighting
yeah so we showed up he knew something
was up cuz you know it wasn't visiting
it wasn't visiting hours he said they
called us and I walked in there you know
and I said they called us they said
you're kind of uh uh they're not
comforable right now you're in some
discomfort yeah yeah they said they're
going to go ahead and uh give you some
more of that pain medicine he goes yeah
yeah I need some of that and they dosed
him and he fell asleep yeah and he died
at 6 o00 in the morning 6:45 like 6:45
in the morning and just kept hitting him
with more
morphine I was watching the his blood
pressure was already real low and that
started to falter and it flat flatlined
and then one by one all the other ones
Flatline then gone but he didn't know
what hit him he was he was knocked
out yeah so Tom was there and his cousin
Scott was there and his aunt Christa was
there they pretty much stayed all night
right didn't you guys you stayed all
night yeah and um when he died [__]
me and Scott presented arms cuz we're
both ex service and [__] Scott is ex
Army he was in the 101st and ex Navy at
the same time the Navy pimped him out to
the 101st over in Afghanistan so he
um after he died we both presented arms
we played [__] uh Amazing Grace
bagpipe version oh did you really yeah
you out of the tablet played Amazing
Grace [__] oh that's nice out of the
tablet yeah I didn't know you did that
yeah and then uh we left yeah we left
now they're uh they're having a a
ceremony for him but I couldn't stay for
all that that's mostly for friends I was
with him so yeah they said you not to
stay for cuz they couldn't decide like
they were like well maybe it's Saturday
and maybe it's Monday and Tom's like
look I can't stay that long you know
what I mean yeah was they're like oh
okay yeah go back cuz you you were with
him yeah for people that hadn't seen him
and [__] that hadn't seen him in one
yeah and he's you won't see his body
he's good he's
cremated yeah they're just going to have
like a wake yeah that's the same like
that's the same thing my grandmother and
actually when my grandmother died she's
like I don't want a funeral upit she's
like you know and
um he gave me his truck yeah but I
didn't drive it back it's a Ford F-150
2003 with about 230 mil 230,000 miles on
it it's in good condition though he had
upgraded it had a rear view camera and
everything
red um it was solid truck but it got 12
miles to a gallon yeah and I'm not
driving that [__] thing back man
because he told me you rented what was
it a Toyota Camry yeah he rented a
Toyota Camry from Enterprise to drive
there yeah and when he got back he said
I got all the way there on a tank and a
half right you said a tank and a half I
went no less
really I went there and back on a tank
and a half [__] me did you really I
thought you meant you went one way on a
tank and a half I was like wow that's
good but wow that's even better No Ex
well no two and a half two and a half
tanks okay it was about a tank each way
still that's really good yeah and when I
came back I had still had a when I came
here I had a half a tank because it was
get it got 40 miles to a gallon it's 500
Miles God damn 500 miles that bad man it
has that was a badass car it was a 2003
Toyota camon I [__] loved it3 20 23 a
22 Yeah 23 it was a 23 it was this year
or you know last year and I thing had
the best cruise control I've ever
[__] had
you could set it to cruise at 80 and if
a car got in front of you it had radar
it was slow down it match the speed of
that car and when it got what got out of
your way you it
accelerated [__] badass we're just
I'm so used to driving my old 2004 which
doesn't have anything on yeah I could go
down and [__] while it was on cruise
control go down hit the paddles and try
and select what how many miles an hour I
wanted it to cruise at you could go up
or down and it had a central display
with cameras and it had the Bluetooth
and I'm [__] jamed the music [__]
I got Google Google
[__] Earth Google Earth going and
listening to
[__] Wang listening to Wang listening
to listening to Wang's [__] show well
because he has a bunch of videos up that
are like seven hours long I was
listening to like the I put on the
selection where he had like two and a
half hours once and you could use the
paddles to [__] go to the next video
right so you can go through his whole
catalog never lost [__] connection
the whole way and um it was good I was
modern era man and they yeah and uh they
built a bunch of roads in the Deep South
so I was able didn't have to go to buuy
and then cut up came out of the Florida
Panhandle and jumped across the skinny
part of Alabama and then came out
through the backside of [__] I've
never been in that PL part of
Mississippi and then showed up coming
through the back roads the backway of
heidleberg and show I was like man I
know I'm only 5 miles i' have never seen
this place and then then I was there at
the
destination it was spooky out there much
easier just Country Roads real [__]
windy 45 mph speed limit it still it
still saved me like two hours yeah
that's excellent yeah I wasn't going 45
though I was going more like 60 well
yeah see I never go to
[__] and on the way there that final two
hours didn't see a car really didn't
pass a car never saw one that's how
desolate that place
is that's crazy yeah yeah I was trying
to figure out because it's like I know
it's about a 9ish hour drive yeah
because I remember when I was waiting
for you to come home like on Wednesday
night after I finished the show I saw
that you would sent me like a voicemail
and you said oh I think I'm in
Tallahassee or I'm in around Tallahassee
and so I was like [__] I can't even
remember how far Tallahassee is from
here it's about 3 hours and 40 minutes
from Eustace like tellas is so I get
there man there's all kind I made all
kinds of videos Jenny's got them loaded
up we're going to play the videos and it
should be it's like 10 minutes worth he
just did like little should be that we
can uh that you'll be able to hear us
hear the video and US simultaneously I
think that that should happen yeah we
may not have I may not have to comment
though well because a lot of it has your
audio on but like I can turn the audio
off yeah Danny said sick truck hopefully
you keep it um no I'm sell it yeah he's
having he's having his aunt um sell it
yeah they're going to sell it and yeah I
left it there us some money it's worth
more money in Mississippi than it is
here yeah and it was just that's what
they're looking for like you said cuz he
was thinking about it before he's like
well maybe I should just like turn the
car the the rental car in in Mississippi
and then drive the truck back yeah but
he's like this truck only gets like 12
14 miles to the gallon so it's going to
SP like cost me a lot more money in gas
like going back yeah it was like 12
miles hour 12 12 M 12 gallon 12 mil to a
gallon highway and like 11 miles to a
gallon [__] City see that's not
acceptable it looked good the truck
looked good but that was a field truck
it didn't have carpeting or anything it
was all rubber mats in the inside it was
real basic
interior um because that's that's what
he was hunting out of it's something you
could clean with a pressure washer
inside that's what they want in
Mississippi that's not what you want in
Florida in Florida here a truck is like
a prestige item it look it goes down a
road with a whole bunch of lights on it
it looks like a [__] UFO coming
at you they're [__] 10t tall they got
a whole disco [__] balls and display
beaming on the ground truck nuts huge
[__] lights they're obnoxious man
they got [__] nine Set of Lights on
the front of them some lights that beam
straight down on the ground [__] two
sets of headlights and then another set
on the [__]
roof it is very obnoxious yeah and the
stereo system in the back it's in the
[__] bed with the [__] speakers
pointed out so it blasts all on the
person directly behind them right well
like I said that's it's just it's for
[__] it's for [__] it's for
[__] yeah only [__] it's like
look I'm going to Blind everybody and
make everybody deaf on the highway make
everybody listen to my shitty ass
[__] it's country and rap hybrid
music boom boom boom you could hear the
[__] base [__] two miles away yeah
yeah and he's a [__] redneck people
like our neighbor two houses not our
neighbor neighbor but that guy two
houses down that it's like I'm surprised
actually now that I mention it I haven't
heard his stereo this evening yeah maybe
he went out usually it be rattling the
wall because it's Friday you know what I
mean so if I had a truck it'd look like
some out of bad BS now didn't your you
remember when your dad when we lived at
the old house in Sanford um your dad
came to visit us for Thanksgiving right
and didn't he drive that truck the whole
way yeah yeah I thought I recognized
that truck well he had money he had
money he didn't spend it you know he
spend it well he didn't spend it on his
house I'm G show you guys the house yeah
t got video of the house man I [__] I
got up I was going damn I can't believe
this CU
um I would I I lived there for almost
most of the Summers of my youth starting
off in like 1980
1981 and it's like a time capsule it's
unchanged it's still like 1981 it's just
it has modern television and [__] that's
about the only mod only he changed he
spent all that time [__] smoking in
there all the walls were yellow yeah and
his had his mama seen that his mama
would have freaked out he didn't clean
he didn't [__] clean the the any of
the curtains either all the curtains
were yellow from [__] tar I feel like
well when dudes live alone I don't feel
like they never they never wash curtains
or walls or anything didn't wash walls
or sometimes they'll clean other stuff
but they they don't think of it and he
stopped smoking four or five five or six
years ago after that bypass yeah but
still he didn't clean up all the he
didn't clean the walls right he was
infirm yeah you
know and uh but here what's the first
video oh wait Zan said how many miles
was it to get there about 500 each way
yeah I think it's yeah he said about 600
it's something like that yeah it was
almost a 9h hour drive yeah it's like a
9 hour drive but I'll tell you what
though in that Toyota that it was a
[__] sweet drive it was easy just
because of that Cru just because of that
[__] high-tech cruise control that
made that [__] just a breeze and all the
entertainment that you can have in there
time just [__] flies that's not way
it was when I was young making them big
old [__] trips on with a damn Thomas
book map [__] map books God remember
that that sucks so hard and then you're
writing it out and you're plotting
[__] plot how many miles on it you
got it all written down okay when's that
turn coming you have you have your yeah
so bad and you're stopping all the time
you're trying to you don't know where
fuel stops are going to be there's a lot
more
roads in the South so you can go a
direct shot and there's a lot more fuel
stops and rest areas lots of rest areas
yeah seemed like there was a rest area
whenever I wanted
one and the rest areas are nice they're
not they're not what they were back in
the ' 80s yeah I said A lot's it's
better nowaday
doing road trips and stuff it's much
much easier they're clean they got
guards in there yeah back in the old
days it's like I was scared to like stop
at a rest stop back then cuz it's like
am I going to get murdered today let's
see the guards keep all the [__]
hookers and all the [__] drug dealers
and weird [__] that used to happen over
the [__] truck stops [__] glory
holes dudes trying to suck your dicks
and
[__] yeah well that's what Pro went down
there to go [__] get his dick sucked
but Pro tip if you see a hole in the
wall in the bathroom don't stick your
dick unless you want it to go into some
random mouth cuz that's what might
happen Tammy says my mom's viewing was
today uh I wish I could have been with
her when she died she had been all alone
in her apartment terrible see that's
like yeah that's really sad well she
probably didn't know that she was
dying did she she probably just died
yeah suddenly my dad knew he was dying
I'm just glad he had several days he had
years warning he knew he was he was gone
yeah he was sick of it yeah I mean you
even talk to him on the phone like yeah
you know every so often and he would
just be like man I'm sick of this [__]
and he he just wasn't feeling good he
couldn't go fishing like he used to do
his friends weren't hanging out with him
or couldn't take him anywhere because he
wasn't wasn't well enough right right
right but you know it's so
but I'm just I'm kind of glad that you
left a little bit earlier than you were
going to because you were actually going
to leave on the Monday but you left on
the Saturday instead and he died on
Tuesday morning like early Tuesday
morning so I feel like it's good that
you actually got to go and like hang out
with him for a couple of days like
before that happened you know what I
mean hang out I hung out with uh Joey
trible and his wife um um what was her
name [__]
Clarice and then uh uh met their
son and
um this funny we're just talking my
dad's the last white man in in hiber
it's almost all it's it's like 99% 99%
black he's the last white guy he was
like a
leged yeah he's real popular and his
caregiver was clarice's Sister Kesha I
met her and kha' come over every day
make sure he was all right do his some
of his medical stuff and she came to see
him before he died she's like you know I
love you goes I love you too she gave
him big kiss on the M she she goes I had
him I had him dancing and everything you
know
but he used to she she came and told me
stories you know that he used to take
her to lunch you ready to get something
to eat she goes I don't want little Mr
time I'm [__] I'm full she goes I
don't want to hear that get in the
truck take take her Awards and [__] yeah
yeah Kea was cool
fing when you know he's dying and I go
Dad you didn't tell me you had a black
girlfriend he's like oh
yeah he said all kinds of funny [__]
when he saw me he's like uh I said Dad
it's me he's like yeah cuz he didn't
recognize me at first yeah cuz he hadn't
seen you he had seen me and I said cut
my hair and got he go you never see me
bald and it it with a beard he go look
at my hair look at my beard and he goes
yeah yeah that's
right look good looks good yeah and then
and then I said yeah and then like about
two or three minutes later he looked at
me he goes mused up he couldn't talk
real well it was a real strain to talk
and I said yeah yeah yeah yeah so I
started [__] posing for him yeah yeah
look good look
good then like 15 minutes later they're
all talking to him he he looks at me he
goes mus up he said yeah yeah yeah yeah
he couldn't really speak too well it was
like uh it was
um little short sentences you know two
three words four words that was because
it was just he did just too much of a
strain on him
yeah but uh
he was trying to put on he tell you what
there was not an ounce of fear in him
you know kind of [__] grateful that
he put on such a good face around us you
know he he probably was scared of dying
but he wouldn't show it around us yeah I
kind of think he didn't want to make us
[__]
uncomfortable but he kept saying let me
die but he would say but we didn't hear
that he would saying the uh saying that
to uh to them when we weren't there and
he go looks at me he goes I'm
I said no you're not he what makes you
think
so said them numbers looking better than
they did yesterday that you could come
out of this and he just didn't say
nothing breathing you know kind of
struggling with it he goes put my feet
up feet down he'd do feet up feet down
in 10 10 20 seconds he just wasn't
comfortable yeah nothing was working on
him couldn't regulate his body
temperature too well either but
um you know so we went there like two or
three days visited him uh three times it
was only like little 10-minute visits
but we when we showed up at 10: when the
lights were off he knew something was
wrong yeah he he knew he knew the time
ah had he said they said you're not
feeling good they're going to come in
here and give you some that pain
medicine he goes yeah yeah yeah yeah get
yeah they can't even give it to me he's
like yeah yeah and then he blanked out
and fell asleep
snoring never woke up
yeah which is that was the best option
for him yeah well and like you said it's
um you know it's sad but it's a lot of
there was no other option yeah that's
the thing he was suffering and it's like
and it's a lot of weight off you too
because we've been worried about it
since he went through the bypass yeah
like you just kept waiting to get that
phone call waiting to get that phone
call and it could have gone a lot worse
for him he could have lingered for a
long long time and not seen any results
they they may euthanasia is not legal in
Mississippi but they have ways of what
they call alleviating pain it's morphine
yeah so they can find excuses to give
you morphine yeah when you're dying and
they knew he was dying the only thing
was keeping them alive was that those
pain or excuse me blood pressure
medicine and they knew that once they
stopped
that if he couldn't keep his blood
pressure up on his own and he had a do
not resuscitate order he said he didn't
want to be resuscitated so they knew
that once they took him off of that and
his heart started pressure started to
drop they knew that you you could apply
pain relief to that which like I said
that's yeah that's really the best thing
to do in those situations they just kept
piling that pain relief on I saw what
they were giving him and was like going
damn I don't know if it was morphine but
it was a morphine like substance like I
said making people suffer is not no cool
no he he just fell asleep didn't and
then just slowly shut yeah he probably
liked it and that was um uh best thing
for him cuz he couldn't back off of that
and what's he going to do go back home
and just you know laying in bed for 6
months never been able to get out just
fighting and [__] trying to fight one
thing and losing another battle and it's
just no it's just it's just his body was
shot and he was he had terminal cancer
anyway yeah even if you were to fix a
lot of that [__] the cancer would have
killed him I mean that I mean if I was
in that situation I would really want to
live like that yeah no he do
anything fighting it for the rest of his
life in pain and you're uncomfortable
all the time it's like it would get old
you know what I mean like I said I went
he was already old he was already I went
through the same thing with my
grandmother she had stomach cancer and
you know they did surgery but they
didn't they thought they got it all and
they didn't and then they were like well
we can do chemo and she was like nah
[__] that she's like I don't want to go
through all that she's like I'll be sick
all my hair will fall out it's like I'm
just going to feel like crap and it
probably won't help so you guys ready to
see the videos If you ready to see the
videos we'll play them yeah are they in
order um like I said I didn't really
know like what the time deal was like
cuz I downloaded all of them from
Facebook and then I put them all in my
video editing program and when I put
them in there it seemed like it didn't
put them in in chronological order so
what I tried to do is I just tried to
like group them together so they might
not be in chronological order okay all
right this is a heidleberg Mississippi
it's a little German Town let me talk to
him first it's a little German Town
German Village all right I don't think
it ever had any more than a thousand
people in it at its height um it's about
12 miles outside of Laurel Mississippi
now Laurel Mississippi is kind of the
center of an ongoing long cable TV
program called uh Hometown Hometown
which we I I only just found out about
it it's on HGTV I guess yeah it's been
going on for about eight years Hometown
is a home
renovation uh show where some people
people from Laurel there yeah it's like
a married couple and yeah they can take
a $100,000 home that's from the ' 50s or
something and turn it into just man that
house would be worth a million yeah we
watched a couple of them last night and
I was like wow this is pretty fun right
they were doing that down in Laurel's
historic D
District um but all the money got sucked
out it used to be pretty wealthy well or
they say it was middle class which is
real well which is a lot of money for
the south at the time where that [__]
was booming and it had an upper class
that was very wealthy big [__]
Southern mansions and big [__] fake
Plantation houses they weren't
plantations they were downtown but they
looked like a plantation house so if you
ever watch our town or the hometown
Hometown it's called two words yeah two
home on HGTV yeah we're watching it on
HBO Max HBO Max has cuz I have that and
um they have all eight seasons
apparently yeah and that's actually
where my dad grew up but he moved out to
a little satellite Village called hi
highberg
and this is it the U and it's in the
videos I'll show you outside of his
[__] up 1950s
house um and then inside and outside I I
forget me me and my cousin Scott talking
about how yellow the walls were we
joking about it like I said I'm not
Scott mom's in it which is my dad's
sister she's laughing yeah Christa her
name is Christa yeah yeah I'll put it on
I'm I'm going to run to the bathroom and
get more but I'll put this on now they
should like ask them because they should
be able to hear you talking as well as
the you talking on the video yeah so
we'll see how it goes all right so here
they go come here I lived here for a
little
while this is my dad's
house it's freezing it's cold as hell
paint on this
thing
damn wow it needed to be painted real
badly across the street right there old
school that's where that's the
truck that's the truck he left that's
the car I read came in here with
this it needed to be washed but it was
pretty good condition this house looking
needs to be painted
bad found that is a sure enough Bullet
Hole Bullet Hole he accidentally shot a
[__] hole through the [__] window
man and put a cotton ball in it that is
a bullet
hole if his mom found found about that
about that she'd be [__] freaking out
you [__] shot a hole in the
window beat his
ass oh
man yeah straight up time capsule it is
a time capsule got you in Korea got a a
[__] modern TV on a 1970s [__]
stand plastic pictures of all the family
there's
Casey but
my dad is a
teenager me
Scott who's this H that might be no
that's biver that's yeah that's my
granddad right there that might be great
Grandad
great that's a gun
safe this is all for reloading making
ammunition
this is this is the reason it's a Civil
War toy gun that's a toy gun from the
Civil
War it works it shoots percussion C toy
gun from the Civil War I remember that
[__] like it was yesterday yeah
like Y show OG mccor look how old that
spice is that's from like the
70s look at that look at that he's not
cooking he's not cooking is he he's not
clearing his [__] maybe feed yeah
somebody's feeding cook I mean he cook a
little bit like Mom had to clean the
stove up yeah but it's like hot dogs
right meat [__] you know yeah man those
[__] plates M little mama painted
that [__] yeah it's like just she
hand painted all that stuff I got the
chicken over there like in the bag like
[__] that that damn green chicken man
yeah with the [__] jelly beans in
that [__] Scott's uh working for the
Navy and that isn't that Navy contractor
for the US running stff contractors out
and [__] to do maintenance Cruise inside
the Navy that's what do right here
that's my old military school scho dress
uniform I didn't know where it went my
dad had
it this old gun cabinet looks like
something from the Civil War it's a
Civil War era gun cabin that's my dad's
room my dad's room it actually looks
pretty good it's all wood here it's all
wood it's cuz it doesn't have any damn
carpeting or not carpeting it doesn't
have any uh
uh wall just a little bitty Southern
house AG pretty nice here this is what
it looks like central air went out so
he's just using window units that's what
the neighborhood looks like I know the
half had old neighborhood had it one
time but he didn't he didn't bother
fixing it it was just cheaper to buy
time 89 yeah no before that this is like
something out of dam it's a little low I
think is it yeah this is like something
more like Yeah from late 70s and 80s
okay they're it's aged so much floor
isn't
straight was it straight though I think
it was straight our volume and their
volume yeah I think it was look at these
uh look at these curtains
man [__] they're like four different
colors of yellow you you can't really
they don't really show doesn't really
show up in the uh in the video here but
yeah this place is uh very
vintage this is like a a [__] cabin
out of the movies
now NE well what it is is he never
painted it and never changed anything
never never did any wallpaper look at
that color I mean look at the damn
difference in the color from all the
smoking can't really see it watch no you
can see it watch can't see
this
yeah you can see it he's [__] there
was chain smoking in here man everybody
did
[__] we uh cleaned the spot we made a
huge clean spot we sprayed some cleaning
solution up there and it was like look
it was like pure [__] tar and
nicotine started [__] coming down it
got
better that it clean up actually you can
see the you can see that the place very
clean yeah little circle yeah Chris is
mad I made a clean spot yeah you know
you [__] up you made a clean spot you
made a
clean I on the damn floor and I'm sorry
I did
it right made a clean spot she made a
clean spot like [__]
what am I done yeah them cigarettes
they're bad for
[Laughter]
you it's my old uniform he had
it you brought that back there yeah I
got it yeah I thought you brought them
back
yeah I know you had you had one like
that yeah here that's the real one
that's the one I wore in Egypt right or
one of them I didn't save the other one
I knew you had one here here yeah sh but
I'd never seen those ones yeah I love
this he sent me this and I just laughed
my ass
off recliner
damn this is like a bed man what the
[__] what the [__] damn talk about
recliner this shit's [__] that's why
he never did anything he just laid in
this [__] he couldn't get a bed
that was the Chinese buffet right yeah
Chinese buffet yeah he went there a
couple of times waitress to flirt with
me I took a picture of him yeah look
look look and I was like I think she
knows you're filming her bro she didn't
care show you some real Southern shap
here
where houses and [__] this is downtown
Laurel it's like some [__] from the
haunted
house
R around here when I was a
kid stuff like
that this is the Saw Mill Square Mall
where I used to come when I was a kid
there's a belk here now of all things
that's a belk but this is where my dad
took me to see the thing like twice I
saw [__] uh all kinds of good movies
here I saw Flash Gordon here it wasn't
called Southwest theater back in those
days I forgot what it was but you could
walk in that door and right on the right
was a [__] Aladdin's Castle [__]
arcade used to [__] $20 in there that
was like a [__] ton of money back then
buying
tokens the anchors are all gone it's
just a [__] mall now Zach said you
should do a Dan Bell voice when you
showed
this I did do a Dan Bill move on that's
Dan Bell oh is it okay yeah too much
testosterone well it's not a dead Mall
but it's it's not super active as the
way as it used to
be yeah I remember what this place was
like back in the
80s
yeah what is that one one Buck oh it's a
dollar store yeah
okay is that even open nothing's really
popular yet just sitting on them damn
chairs yeah this is where that arcade
used to be long time ago they changed it
and this is where you used to see these
movies all the time so there still I
forgot the name of what this theater
used to
be used be called Southwest wow yep
there still alens in there just named
something else aliens too for the first
time Aliens too I saw there I love this
look how [__] giant this at the
hospital look how giant that is it's
it's it's live it's full size and they
got bab Jesus back there going oh [__]
it oh [__] it got a little baby Jesus
Cemetery this right here is where David
Key's old house was it burned down and
behind this was the woods that we used
to play in and that we used to burn down
all the time that's where all that [__]
happened cool again right over there but
it's overgrown now it's just an empty
lot but this is the Laurel Cemetery we
used to play here when we were kids this
is usually open but it's closed now we
got to take a weird route to get out but
that's where we were scared of [__]
Jason and [__]
it was a nice house this is what a WS
looks like WS it's a cute
Place yeah it's a Mississippi only chain
called Wards there's 80 locations I
think that yeah I got a little Octon
girl as a damn
mascot yeah I had I had heard of it but
they don't have any outside of
Mississippi as far as I know yeah that
that was the end of it yeah okay cuz he
was like cuz cuz he showed me that and I
was like what the hell is that is it a
restaurant or a bar bar or something
Wards is uh Mississippi's version of
McDonald's it's not really like
McDonald's it's more kind more like
Sonic kind of like Sonic but it has
breakfast yeah does does Sonic have
breakfast I don't know I don't I haven't
been to breakfast is the breakfast is
kind of um just biscuits like biscuits
with sausage biscuits Bon waffle kind of
like Waffle House or Hardies more like
yeah um better than more like Waffle
House but it's it's not like full sit
down breakfast breakfast sandwiches they
might have some they might have some
some sit down type breakfast what' you
get there you didn't tell me got the
double burger it's called the double big
one they got the big one and the little
one the double big one yeah they got the
double big one they got the big one the
double big one they got the little one
and a I think they got a double little
one and then you can have a you could
have it with chili on it ew it's good I
didn't get it with chili though so
sloppy but I mean the whole they don't
put a whole lot well the whole point of
a burger is like to pick it up and eat
it with your hands if you have chili on
it you can't it they didn't put a whole
lot on it it it wasn't all messy they it
was just the same chili they used on
chili dogs you get chili dogs you get
catfish there fried catfish okay now
that's more my speed yeah that's what I
be in southern food yeah and um they got
a I think I got pictures of the Little
mascot yeah you sent me pictures I
didn't put those in there though I just
put the video the mascot is kind of
new and if you understand Southern
Culture you
see Mississippi is about probably about
35% black it's the blackest state of all
the
states and um more than half the
locations are in Black areas and it's
usually black girlss working in them
usually so the the mascot is a is a
mixed girl see and she looks like what
we would call an Old South octar or or
or quadr which one quarter but black or
just light skinned she's a lightskinned
chick well they kind of have a little
bit of a um I feel like a World War II
pinup kind of look to it also you know
what I mean which I like that I don't
have them on this um yeah phone but I
got him in conversations John gor said
it looks like Dawn of the Dead Mall yeah
yeah kind of not it's only one story
though yeah cuz don't want in Don of
dead was a it was two stories that was
two stories yeah yeah what was that that
was called the um that was in
Pittsburgh I monroville Monro okay see
that's how much of a hor I don't know I
haven't seen it
so was she's so much of a nerd she would
know where that [__] was I forgot for a
second but I was like oh yeah Monro the
Monro mall that's what I don't think
it's there anymore I don't is it still
open anybody that lives up there s said
I was born in ' 89 so I was the last
generation to appreciate the arcades
yeah arcade were
yeah that's
uh yeah Dan also said we have chili
burgers out here in the casinos yeah I
mean I'm not I'm not a massive fan of
chili like I like I could take it or
leave it you know what I mean and if I I
don't know I I feel like if I have a
burger I don't mind if they're a little
bit sloppy but I don't want like a bunch
of like liquid [__] on there you know
what I mean it's not liquid I know but
I'm just saying yeah it no it's you e
the video of my dad dying you didn't put
no I didn't put that in put no I didn't
well I thought about it and I was like
that might be a little too much it
wasn't really of that because you sent
me that like several hours before that
happened yeah it was just so it was just
basically like a few seconds of like the
darkened room with him you had videos
you can see much of anything yeah that's
cuz you sent me that before I went to
sleep and then I woke up at 7:30 and I
got the message that he had died yeah at
6:45 so because I sat up
like talking to you until 2 I think our
time because you're because Mississippi
is one hour
earlier and that was another thing that
was confusing too because when he was
driving home on Wednesday night he said
oh I'll be home about midnight and then
midnight went by and I'm sitting there
going oh [__] what happened but he got
home about quarter to one and then he
was like I was like thank [__] I was
like I was starting to get worried he's
like yeah I forgot about the time
difference he's like I'm at 1:00 a.m.
that's the W that's the Ws girl
yeah it's actually do you have any
videos of your dad talking no
unfortunately no but I've heard him talk
and the the impression quote unquote
that you do that sounds that's what he
sounds like he sounds just like that he
sounds just like that yeah yeah Mur horn
said is that Mississippi yeah yep it's
called Wards and it's um it's a
Mississippi only chain how many you said
there was 80 0 80 of them in Mississippi
only yeah and they're good real
good
yeah I feel like I had heard of it but
they got a website too Wards restaurants
yeah and there I probably put the
quality on par with maybe like
Sonic but it has things that you're
going to want in the South it's going to
have [__] fried catfish I'm sure it's
got cornbread but I didn't check we can
probably get
it cornbread yeah I haven't had
cornbread in a while it probably has
cornbread oh they had a homemade root
beer
yeah I saw that like when you sent me
the pictures like it said that on the
sign I was like oh it wouldn't surprise
me if they had if they had banana
pudding in there I mean they got to have
Nana pudding yeah Nana P Nana pudding is
vanilla pudding vanilla wafers my
grandma used to make that all the time
Vanilla Wafers I don't like it though
vanilla
pudding banana slices and whipped cream
and you it kind of Cals into
this this layers of it that sounds real
wear it and and and all the the Nilla
wafers absorb the moisture and it turns
into like a pie and it's got to be the
neisa
nisf it's got to be those cuz they have
knockoff ones but they're not quite as
good but like I said I don't really like
bananas I'm not a big fan of banana
flavor if you like key lime pie you'd
like that imagine if key lime pie was
banana with with wh cream don't don't
don't disparage key lime pie like that
well see cuz I like key lime pie but I
do not like banana put in at all well
you don't like she doesn't like bananas
I don't like bananas so you know but you
know people that like bananas would like
it I don't like bananas and I especially
put recipe in the book yeah and I
especially don't like like fake banana
flavor that's even worse than there
isn't any fake banana flavor in no no no
it has actual banana I don't want you to
confuse the issue soil soil the name
name bana pudding and it's not banana
pudding is Nana or or or Nan Nan pudding
Nan pudding or Nana without a g on the
end yeah you have to leave the g n it's
probably spelled banana but that's not
how it's pronounced that's Nana or Nana
banana pudding banana pudding yeah
shit's [__] great you make it in a
big [__] Bowl yeah yeah like I said
my grandma used to make it all the time
yeah you scoop it out of there make it
deep and then you scoop it out of there
with a big Serving Spoon B yeah cuz it's
not super solid it's kind of Gloppy yeah
it's kind of Gloppy yeah and if you
don't want to put the whip put you can
put the whipped cream on it after it's
in the bowl if you want that's some
people do it that way some people have
it layered in there but it tends to
break down or or put or you know what I
mean like they'll put layers of it and a
layer of whipped cream in there and then
they put more stuff on top but the
whipped cream kind of just h no it's
better to put the [__] whipped cream
on it as a topping yeah I can see that
yeah cuz you put whipped cream on [__]
like before like it kind of goes like it
kind of deflates a little bit it'll
deflate you got to have it come like
right out the [__] [__] you know what
I mean and then you can take n pudd in
and you can make a Blue Bell makes a
nanana pudding ice cream yeah man that
shit's good it's got Nilla wafers in it
and strips of whipped cream in it yeah
cuz Tom's like he's gon to get some of
that I was like well okay but you're
going to eat all of it cuz I'm I found
some Blue Bell there but I could only
find the only one only the classic one
it was was a strawberry there strawberry
is really good they they didn't have no
they have it at Piggly Wiggly yeah yeah
that's a real Southern [__] chain
grocery stores Piggly Wiggly I can't
believe they named an entire grocery
chain Piggly Wiggly yeah Piggly Wiggly
and there's photographs of them back in
the 20s yeah so it's I mean it's been
around forever yeah but it's just like
it's very funny to me that they named it
we had one in Daytona for a little while
but it closed it's kind of like when
Dixie yeah yeah I don't think I ever
went to that one though we usually when
I was a kid we went to Goodings if
anybody is in the South remembers that
um and then after that closed we went to
the wind Dixie yeah which I don't know
if they have those in other parts of the
country that might be a southern thing
too is wind Dixie is a southern thing
too right just like kind of just like
Publix says yeah yeah we don't we don't
got any of those well I mean we have
other we have Aldi we
have um Costco Sams we have all that um
Food Lion although I think that might
have gone bankrupt right I'm trying to
think of like grocery stores that used
to be well when I where I used to work
where I used to live in Daytona there
was um a mile down the road there was a
Windixie on one side and then there was
a food line on the other side and then
otherwhere in the town we had Publix and
we had Albertson I don't think I ever
went to the Albertson though and then we
had like fancier [__] like Whole Foods
and stuff but I you know I'm too Burg to
go in there so so the truck's being sold
it's being sold through the
family probably go for 3.5 or 4,000
that's not bad I'm thinking it'll be
that but I said sell it for whatever you
can get and then uh even if it was only
2,000 it's still you know we're going to
use that as a down payment price for a
car yeah because I said either because
we can use your car as a trade that's
what I was saying I was like if you
bring the truck back I said we could
trade in the truck and the car and get a
better car or they could sell it and we
could have you know what I mean because
we do need another car yeah we buy a car
I could AFF four probably $14,000 car
$112,000 car to [__] be awesome yeah
I mean had 3,000 we really do need a new
we had that car as a trade in another 3
or 4,000 on there that could be $5,000
off yeah so we only have to finance the
rest it' be a lot better payment a lot
easier payment cuz s doesn't have a car
anymore like he he sold his car a long
time ago he just has motorcycles I have
a car but it's old so we don't drive
that much we really don't so you know
what I mean I mean we're going out to
tonight we go out like once or twice a
month and you know we go to the grocery
store and [__] but that's about it we
don't go any place Camp guy said we
called Piggly Wiggly the hoggly
woly that's awesome did Tom's dad have
any cool guns ask Z yeah he had to have
a Colt 45 or something yeah but all guns
went to uh his best friend and basically
brother he kind of like an adopted
brother who they grew up with because he
he wouldn't stay at his house he only
stayed at my dad's house and William
Whitman and that safe went with it cuz
he knew I couldn't bring that [__] here
yeah that safe weighs thousands of
[__] pounds man um and it's all
computerized but the thing is is the
guns that he had were mostly bolt action
real high Precision rifles that were
real specifically tuned and all that
reloading gear was to reload [__]
Precision Ammo he could shoot he could
make match ammo but it was funny my dad
was mostly doing that [__] out of ritual
because he couldn't see very well yeah
so past 100 yards he would did his
vision wasn't good yeah he was doing sub
MOA shooting from these rifles but he
can't see a, or 1100 yards William
Whitman could his
buddy but they were all bolt action guns
for the most part the only Pistols that
he had were steel pistols old school
steel pistol so those went to William
too and he had a a
1911 uh but it wasn't American 1911 it
was a uh it was a what do you call
it it was a Filipino
1911 and it had a couple upgrades on it
and he had a uh a genuine uh Walter PP K
and stainless he had one of those but
William got it but man what would you
want that
for you know I got a I got damn little
micro TP little Taurus [__] 380s and
you can get little Smith 3 380s that are
half that size and far lighter now with
all these polymer frames I mean I like
steel pistols but I'm not real
sentimental about those things I didn't
grow up grow up with my dad's pistols
those are he only had those for a couple
years so I didn't really know those
guyss the only thing in there that
looked kind of weird looked interesting
is he had a 22 Hornet single shot 22
Hornet Breck breach rifle I had never
seen that 22 Hornet he had that that was
weird but it looked like a break breake
breach shot
gun we had a scope on it though too
scope was mounted on the barrel and you
just broke the breach open it it was
real
retro but 22 Hornet is a [__] odd
caliber it's kind of a cone shaped
little cartridge about that
long less power than 5.56 more than 22
magnum though weird car he was loading
that single shot I don't know why I just
he liked that
he didn't like military stuff that much
not when it came to
rifles he didn't think they were
accurate but he was
wrong the AR-15 could be made very
extremely accurate you just have to know
what to do with it but in the times
where he made formed all of his
opinions those
those parts to build those a match
accurate like free flp barrels and [__]
they weren't available then they're
available now yeah but he didn't really
keep up with that
well that's kind of the thing that's
kind of one of the the hell of getting
old is that you don't keep up with [__]
so it's like the opinions that you
formed when you were younger tend to
linger yeah even though shit's changed
right you know what I mean although his
friend William he kept up on [__]
William was big into steel pistols he
was a champion police pistol match shoot
shooter from back in the 60s and he
still goes to
um what's that big old [__] long
range I don't think he went last year
but every year he goes to [__] this
big long range match where they're
shooting out to a thousand yards and he
placs his well and he's an old guy um C
Perry he does the C Perry shoot matches
and he's also a champion trap shooter
these guys aren't just [__] yahoos
they're Pros you know uh they're
good my dad wasn't that good he didn't
really have the time to but William was
and
uh um
he started with uh you know 1911s and
some of the early Smiths he didn't like
9 mimer like he he was real old school
but
recently remember six years ago he was
talking about shooting and I said what
are you shooting and he goes oh I got a
match acuris Glock with all kinds of say
you're shooting Glock he goes oh hell
yeah he goes that trigger and I said you
like that trigger he goes I do now I
didn't like it when it came out but you
know things change you know he's like
that you know so he's an old dude and
he's [__] rocks with a [__] match
ACC keep on [__] man gota keep yeah the
competition
Glock with and it's got bunch of
competition trigger modifications and
stuff he's good and 9 mimer too back in
the day man even even in the 80s 9
millimeter was kind of scoffed at here
in the US just as in as ineffective
because the hollow points they had for
it weren't very
effective but they're better than they
were yeah Xander said damn he had a
Walther PPK I love that that was James
Bond's gun yeah until you hold one and
shoot one they don't have a very good
trigger pull they're very heavy for
their size they don't carry much ammo I
think it's only about eight nine rounds
so it's big and bulky by today's
standards back in the day that was that
was very Compact and The Recoil is
pretty stiff on it it's not gas operated
it's blowback operated it's just a big
heavy spring and a heavy slide holding
it
closed that little Taurus I have is gas
operated it's like Browning swing link
design
it's light Rec it's Snappy but it's
lighter recoil than that it's like a
little pocket
rocket but they got to the point to
where it was [__] you just increased the
size a little bit more and it's 9
millimet so you're doing that too 380 is
kind
of kind of a moot point you know why why
380 you know why not go 9 mm just a
millimeter longer a couple millimeters
longer might be two a lot
more pressure a lot more power it it's
[__] 30%
hotter and the gun is not that much
bigger than a s super you can make a
real super Compact 9mm and you can still
shoot it you know it's it goes off but
you can shoot it [__] we were [__]
shooting 3 for seven magnums that were
[__] little two shot deringers 37
Magnum that that was back in the day it
[__] a [__] Rocket Man Pocket
Rocket
boom yeah most of it wasted because
there's not enough barrel length there
to burn all that powder huge [__]
Fireball you don't have to hit a
[__] with that it's just so
[__]
intimidating you know [__] Fireball
coming out of there about three feet in
diameter sound about as loud as a rifle
I also wanted to say thank you to zanada
for sending us the PayPal donation yeah
thank you very much earlier today so
that was very nice of you that was very
nice of you so I wanted to make sure
that I mentioned that because I don't
remember if I did I don't think I did uh
Juan says happy Friday how are you to
thank you uh we're doing good doing good
you know been kind of a little bit of a
rough week but you know we're okay we're
okay going out tonight a little bit
later about an hour from now yeah Mur
Hornet saying Filipinos built 1911 from
scatch yeah the Filipinos are good with
guns and they got they're kind of sim
similar laws to the US you can get AR15s
you can get anything down there and they
they love guns they're good with them
it's because they fought the Japanese so
they're not going to get rid of guns
they're paranoid about that and they
don't have a [__] high crime rate
anyway but yeah they can take take a
cult 1911 they can make one out of a
damn file they had companies that would
just file them did a lot of hand workk
they they're they're they they're good
and um and
the they're affordable a lot more
affordable than [__] Colt I'm not
even sure Colt still exists I think I
guess it does it's just it's not the
same company as it was and it may have
never been the company you thought it
was either Colt wasn't that good they
had good
quality their design teams are terrible
anytime they came up with something new
it sucked Colt 2000 sucked Colt double
eagle that [__] sucked I mean it wasn't
incompetent it's just that the thinking
behind him was behind you
know Murder Hornet said I was a butcher
at Piggly Wiggly in Florida oh
yeah I don't think I might have gone
into Piggly Wiggly but I was probably a
little kid I mostly remember going in
Goodings when I was a kid and then later
wind Dixie you know what I mean but we
did have a Piggly Wiggly but I don't
remember if I went in there or not I
probably did
yeah Zan said no problem Jenny I sent
Tom a movie for you guys to review when
you get the chance okay yeah we'll
absolutely do that um yeah we got
actually um our friend Brian uh when I
was waiting for you to come home on
Wednesday night he was like oh you
should watch um Society of the snow on
Netflix what was that I don't know
honing I don't know that weird sound was
it it was a weird s [__] that was
weird yeah but he said you should watch
that on Netflix and so I was like okay
well I got a couple hours to kill before
Tom com home so I was watching it and I
didn't realize like when I you know when
it came up on the thing and I read the
synopsis because he's like oh it's like
that movie alive which came out in what
like 1992 which is based on the um you
know those uh rugby players they were
from Uruguay right mhm and they um you
know crashed in the plane and ended up
having to eat their dead comrades and
things like that like to survive and um
so the movie is about that so it's
another version of that and so I'm
watching it and I was already kind of
stressed out because I'm like waiting
for Tom to come home and everything like
that and so like the the scene where
like the plane was crashing I mean
obviously I know the story so I knew it
was going to happen but it's just kind
of like I'm watching this [__] and just
like the way they filmed it was like so
horrific and I'm like why the [__] did I
watch this and it was just like it was I
was freaking out it's a really good
movie though it's a really good movie it
was actually number one on Netflix when
I was watching it murder hor mentions
the tech 9 okay he wants me to comment
on a Tech 9
for those of you who don't know what the
tech 9 is it's back during the damn uh
Miami Vice
era on Miami Vice you saw a lot of Tech
9 you saw Tech9 in a lot of [__] real
cheesy B movies too uh [__] crussell
[__] Kurt Russell uses one in [__]
Big Trouble in Little chin China it's
kind of like a pistol it's got a [__]
30 round magazine in front of it and a
shrouded uh barrel and uh it's just a
big goofy [__] pistol all
right it was tubular it was kind like a
little submachine gun I made out of
[__] two wheer
steel well during the [__] Miami Vice
craze and [__] the drug dealer craze
you started seeing people buying Tech 9s
they were cheap and they had a 32 round
magazine I didn't believe it was 32 30
or 32 it kind of looked
intimidating but had a terrible trigger
pull they kind of shot slowly po just
crappy the thing is is that Americans
didn't know what the original was that
was actually a pretty in inch made them
and I believe that they were
from Finland or Holland or something
they were a European country and
originally it was going to be a bolt
[__] blowback bolt open operation
fully automatic 9mm submachine
gun now that version didn't have a
firing pin or a hammer it just had a
fixed firing pin on a bolt and it was
[__] very good when they converted it
to semi-auto it had to have a h because
of the ATF regulations you couldn't be
it couldn't be open bolt anymore it had
to fire from a Clos bolt which meant you
had to have a firing pin and a hammer in
it that complicated the
design and the tech 9 had problems like
cracking bolts bolt faces because it
wasn't designed to have a [__]
Channel cut through it and this it
wasn't designed to have mass taken off
the bolt and it just really couldn't
take the it really just couldn't really
take the beating you know once they
turned it into a Clos bolt system so
they tended to crack but it didn't
matter they still worked the Bol face
the bolt face would crack but it would
still [__] work just that there
wasn't real confidence
inspiring and they were cheap
anyway they're gone now they're like a
meme gun you know what I mean the the
the the the tech 9 was the firearm
equivalent of a [__] mullet if you
showed up with that thing you're were
going to get goofed
on but the military original it was a a
machine gun that and I think it even had
a damn class buttstock on it if I
remember correctly and it it was good it
was real good it's just that it didn't
have any military buyers it came out too
late [__] like open bolt submachine guns
out of style they were going more to
things like MP5 which were roller
delayed [__] firing from a closed
bolt more like more like an assault
rifle and submachine guns themselves
were going out why why pistol cartridges
what you know they can shoot rifle
cartridges that's called an assault
rifle it's a lot more size
efficient
but there's one caveat if you want to
suppress it or sound suppress it for
indoor work for like law enforcement you
can go with a pistol cartridges it's
it's less punishing for your ears so
that way you can shoot it indoors and
teams without having to have um without
having to have hearing protection so you
can
communicate contrary to what they're te
showing you on the
movies suppressed weapons do not hide
the fact that shots have been fired you
know shots have been
fired okay you know it's just that it's
not allowed is you're not really quite
quite sure how far away that was or what
caliber that was if that was a rifle or
a pistol you're not quite sure so they
do kind of confuse you but you know
shots have been
fired a suppressed 9mm pistol is about
as loud as an unsuppressed 22 caliber
pistol they're not
quiet they're not they're not silent
that's there are a few of them but
that's very few they're made for silence
but if you shoot a guy with that he's
not silent he screams
okay it's very hard to fight hide the
fact that shots have been
fired let me go get another drink Tammy
says off topic but I finished watching
that lone wolfen Cub TV series
not sure how it compares to the movies
but I really enjoyed it I highly
recommend it it's yeah I'd like to see
it where where can we see it I'm I'll
look it up okay yeah Camp gu said my
wife just watched that the the movie
that I watched um on Netflix about the
rugby players yeah it's like the yeah
yeah they were from Uruguay right and uh
when that happened in the 70s right and
they crashed in the Andy's mountains and
I had forgotten how long cuz I'm
watching the movie and I'm like man they
were there for a long long time like
right I I felt like it was a month but
it was more like two months that they
were there and yeah they ended up having
to like eat the bodies and stuff like
that but it's a [__] up
story I mean a bunch of them survived a
bunch of them died too but I mean a
bunch of them survived but like the
whole first part of it cuz like even
like the first 10 minutes of the movie
obviously they're going to show you the
plane crash and I'm paranoid about that
kind of [__] [__] anyway and so like
so I'm sitting there watching I'm wait
and I know that Tom's like driving like
on the highway so I was like stressed
out about that cuz I'm like oh I hope he
makes it home okay and stuff like that
so I'm watching this movie and then this
[__] plane and they're like like and
people getting crushed by the seats and
like their legs are breaking and she I'm
like oh man why the [__] did I watch
this this like stressed me out so much
but it was like it was a really good
movie though it was really good I saw a
live a long time ago but um cuz that was
based on well this was based on a book
too but I feel like alive which I I want
to say that came out in 1992 I think but
I saw that so long ago that I think I
saw that like a year after it came out
and I haven't seen it since then but
that was based on I don't remember if
they were books that were written
by survivors you know what I mean
because I think this one might have been
but I don't remember if alive was but
alive was pretty good too but it's been
a long time since I've seen it I haven't
seen it since the
90s um yeah Camp guy said I read the
original alive story in reader Digest
Magazine when I was a kid and yeah
that's one of the things reading [__]
like that like I know that it's
statistically really unlikely that
you're going to be in a playe crash but
I don't know man I just don't want to
risk it because because if you do happen
to have the bad luck to be in that like
it'll be the most horrific thing you've
ever [__] experienced and I just
don't want to I don't want to subject
myself I just
don't um let's see I'd eat human ribs if
I had to in order to survive I kind of
lik like in the movie they sort of went
into cuz for a long time they debated
which like I said I guess you would if
you were in that situation especially if
you
weren't starving
yet but I like that they kind of made it
clear I mean these were all Catholics so
they were very worried about you know is
God going to forgive us like for doing
this you know what I mean so I kind of
like that they had that aspect of it
that that gave them like another
motivation for not wanting to do it cuz
some of the people were like no I'm
absolutely not eating people and for a
long time they had to have like a couple
of them had to go out there and like cut
you know this is horrible but they had
to like cut bits off of the dead people
and not tell the other people who it
came from you know what I mean because
they didn't want to but you know after
they were there for such a long time you
know and people kept dying like they had
to eat off of people that they knew who
it was and it was like really traumatic
for them so
I can't imagine like I mean they
survived and everything like that but
it's just like you would never get
[__] over that you just never would
you never would okay Zach said that the
Mac 10 was way better than the [__]
Tech 9 true the semi-auto Mac 10 was
better than the than than the tech 9
pretty much in every way especially
durability but the full auto versions of
the Mac 10 and the full auto versions of
the tech 9 were real similar real
similar cu the I believe the full auto
version of the tech 9 I think it might
have been called the kg-99 I think I
think that's what the name was don't
quote me on that been a long time since
I thought about that thing but the K the
full auto version of the tech 9 got rave
reviews it wasn't quite the same gun it
had a different bolt in it different
trigger mechanism because it was firing
from an Open Boat it was lighter than
the tech 9 and it had a bunch of
accessories suppressors it had a better
buttstock it was pretty good the the
company that made it was a very serious
company the the military version it was
a civilian version that
sucked okay
it um well as Camp guy was saying there
were only a very few that survived maybe
four or five or six um I think at least
according to what I remember and
according to the movie I thought it was
either 14 or 17 people that survived a
bunch of them died too but they were
there for a long time they were there
for like I think it was 2 months or
maybe like over 2 months like that they
were in the mountains and they got
found I mean it was just kind of pure
luck because two of them um hiked out
like they left all that because they you
know were um there was part of the plane
there like part of the fuselage and they
were kind of staying in that like they
got it got buried by an avalanche at
some point it was like it's just I was
talking to I was talking to Zach while I
was watching to the movie like on
Facebook messenger and I was just like
these poor guys it just keeps getting
like worse and worse and um you know
it's like they they're like okay we're
survived and then like the [__]
airplane got buried and they're like
[__] me and they were under for like
four days before they could dig their
way out and [__] like that so but I
think in the end like two of them were
like [__] this we're going to like try
and get into cuz they were going to um
they were going to Chile for a you know
for a rugby match and they were almost
there I think they were only like 10
minutes from
Landing so they were like okay we're
going to hike this way and see if we can
get into Chile but I don't think
anything worked out that way so they
kind of went the other way and it so
happened that two of the guys made it to
this stream like that was kind of far
down the mountain where there had been a
thaw and like a guy on a horse just
happened to see them and then like so
they went back to the camp and like you
know they sent out the helicopters to
pick up the other dudes and stuff like
that but it was like just super lucky
that that happened because man I'm
watching this movie I'm like oh it was
so like like I said I knew that most of
them lived but it was just like [__]
I was just like these poor [__]
people I can't imagine being in that
situation i' be like you know what just
[__] kill me that's it's fine I don't
want to go through this
[__] um Oracle
said I have some sad news to share last
Saturday morning we had to say goodbye
to our cat Ash she was 17 years old oh
yeah oh that's a bum that's a long life
for cat though it is but still I don't
like you know I don't like to think
about it because I mean pooky's only six
but yeah you know Pooky could be around
another 10 10 years 11 years better she
better be yeah she better live forever
bam better live forever
too they both better live forever well
and Beijing is Beijing is what 14 yeah I
think she's 14 yeah she's still going
strong she has little SP spots where her
kidneys start bothering her she starts
throwing up then she stops eating for a
while we'll give her some medicine some
[__] kidney medicine and she shakes
it back and then she comes back okay I'm
good now she be able to hold food down
yeah it's cuz she ate a lizard she was
eating lizards yeah and there's
evidently something that lizards can
carry that can cause a bunch of liver
damage and they say it's kind of the D
It's like a virus you can treat it but
they you never really can cure it yeah
so she keeps having little relaps like
relapses but she always comes back out
of it
yeah guess it's kind of like getting
herpes it just keeps coming back and you
know it'll be better and it'll come
back the weird thing here's the funny
thing so when Tom was gone um Bambi
didn't really seem to act any different
because she has a weird yeah
relationship with you yeah she likes to
run from me and tries to get me to chase
her she doesn't she want she likes me to
Pat her but she doesn't see me as like
part of the family I'm like an outsider
yeah weird yeah she's like I'm not
supposed to be here she [__] loves me
though man she never leaves me alone she
just like she's like my little Shadow
yeah like wherever I am she's right
there if I'm in the office she's
sleeping in the office like all day long
like right by my ja she's a rescue cat
she came from another family maybe there
was a guy there that was mean to her
that's kind of what I think so she kind
of doesn't really trust me or she
forgets about me yeah she'll be okay
once I start petting her and then she
wants to hang out then she hadn't seen
me in a while and I show back up she's
like ah and then she runs who are you
yeah but here's the thing so when Tom
was gone um Pooky was like she was
acting a little bit weird like she was
acting a little confused like where is
Daddy and I was like he's coming back
he's coming back she'd like um cuz Tom
would send me videos or voice messages
or whatever and I'd be sitting in the
bed playing them and pooky would jump up
on the bed and like like I hear him like
yeah like sniffing at the phone like why
is he in this little yeah where is he
this little box in there like what's
going on where's he at like why isn't he
giving me meat sticks right now and um
so there was that but then when Tom
actually came home yeah she was mad at
him yeah she turned her back on me she's
just sitting there looking at me she was
like I I like Pooky where are you where
are you I couldn't find her then I was
petting
bam and uh I turned around and she's
sitting at the end of the hallway just
sitting there watching me and I was like
what you doing po come here and then and
I went over there and picked her up she
didn't run I picked her up and tried to
hold her and then she pushing away she's
like she's like this the whole time I
could hold her she's like get off me
yeah and then I put down on the bed and
[__] and she's like
yeah cuz cuz she thought I did something
bad cuz you left her yeah you ran away
you ran away yeah it it though she she
snapped out of it she got over it after
like a day about a day later but it was
hilarious because she was like clearly
she was very upset with him she was like
you ran away so like when he came back
she was just like oh this [__]
yeah she's like
[Laughter]
yeah cuz Pookie's kind of a daddy's girl
mhm cuz you guys yeah you guys
wrestle you give her meat STI she took
that [__] personally she did yeah she
was very mad she's like I don't know
where you've been but you ran away you
were Tom's like talking to her she like
turned her back yeah turned her back me
like I'm ignoring you la la la she was
like that it was like it was hilarious
it was hilarious she was definitely
jealous she like and he came back and he
was like unpacking
yeah all his stuff and she comes in like
sniffing all his stuff like like where's
this [__] B where's this [__] B yeah
were you hanging out with another kitty
or a doggy or something she didn't
smelling another cat probably what she
was talking probably what she was
thinking yeah was there another
cat or something but she was uh she
thought you were cheating on her yeah or
something might be what is she's like he
went somewhere what was he doing she
want to know what I was doing yeah and
you know from her point of view she's
not really allowed to go anywhere yeah
so why should somewhere that's bad yeah
but I went somewhere so I was bad yeah
yeah she was I tried to tell her because
she would like come up on the bed and be
like what's going on cuz she'd like walk
around on to side of the bed and she'd
be like looking at me like what the [__]
is the deal where like I'm like he's
he'll be back soon he'll be back soon
and she's just like she wasn't like
buying it I don't think but then when
you came back it was like really funny I
didn't expect her to like react that way
I thought she'd be happy but she she
would have to see me at all no she was
just like oh [__] where were you
she was like really mad it was fun
[__] leave just it was so funny yeah
I just thought it was so fun like it
kind of broke my heart a little bit but
it was like super funny to like see her
react like that yeah you did something
bad [__] left didn't come back for
three four days yeah you were in trouble
yeah she's like I'm just like not even
going to for that yeah she didn't like
it I could tell yeah yeah she just
glaring at me yeah she was giving him
the [__] yeah she she has like a really
good um stink eye yeah you can see her
she her facial expressions are are
they're human yeah she has hand raised
her yeah she has very human facial
expression yeah I looked over one time
she was lean up against the wall looking
at me like that made eye contact was
like I was looking at a little person
yeah she's like I
know don't you [__] with
me so I just thought that was so funny
she was just so because because I was
like oh my God she's mad times like yeah
she's mad at me most cats don't hold eye
contact she will yeah she look right at
she'll look try to look into your soul
try to communicate I want I want some
treats I want the meat sticks and then
you going to give me that brush brush
yeah brush my hair she tries to well
she's trying to um telepathically
communicate with you cuz she can't talk
telepathy so she'll like stare at you
like really intensely yeah like you tell
she's trying to like project her
thoughts in your head it's like it's
very funny definitely yeah like
especially when she wants to meet stick
she'll come like to the side of the bed
and and she'll just like stare yeah like
that and she just looks at you for a
really long time Allison said um hey I'm
feeling sick from my vertigo oh I'm
sorry so I'm not going to stay but I
wanted to pop in briefly to give my
regards and condolences to Tom and his
extended family and all of Tom's dad's
friends RP yeah we were talking about
that a lot
earlier um you know everything's okay it
all worked out yeah Tom's okay the
uncertainty is gone we knew he was he
was going he wanted to
go
yeah it's kind when you're in that
situation if you kind of grieve or mourn
over it you're you're just being selfish
you're just mourning for yourself all
right well there's nothing wrong with
that though yeah the thing is who am I
to tell him he's got to stay here he
lived 77 years with all his [__]
problems bad diabetes and [__] he was
very lucky to make it to 77 a guy of his
profile the way he was he should have
died in probably late 60s early 70s he
had a lot of bonus
time the odds were very much against him
just his dad only lived to like late 40s
yeah his dad died young
yeah so no he did good of heart failure
some kind of heart failure yeah you know
that was in the 60s or no late 50s they
didn't know what he died of they didn't
do autopsies back then he was watching
fights on television and he was [__]
rooting on some [__] black dude
fighting it's like you can't get and
then he he called U that's right you
punched that mother he called Catherine
and he goes hey Catherine as his wife my
grandmother and he goes he goes can you
give me something to drink I'm thirsty
and she yeah yeah I'll give you
something to drink he's watching and she
gave him something to drink and he goes
[__] must have hurt my
elbow and she goes she goes you hurt
your elbow yeah I hit it on something he
set the drink down then she went back
into the up the stairs and back into the
kitchen and cuz he was in a he was in a
den that was actually kind of lower than
the rest of the house and she could hear
him down there [__] young get him get
him yeah get him get him that [__] don't
want that's right that's right you know
I was like you know they can't hear you
yeah yeah yeah that's right that's
right and then it
um then she realized that she hadn't
heard him in a
while and she was like what happened did
the guy lose the fight you know what I
mean so she goes down there to go see
you know what the deal was and she when
she was coming downstairs she saw him in
front of the chair you know where that
where he was sitting well actually he
was standing in front of the chair he
wasn't sitting she said you stand in
front of that chair [__] rooting
rooting a dude on fighting I don't
remember which boxer it was my dad
knew and he was in front of that chair
on the
ground and she go what's going on what
happened and she went over there and
rolled him over and he was already
dead she called I can't imagine 911 yeah
and he was like late 40s I think he was
like like
47 my dad was young like 10 you know
like that I just can't imagine with that
I
mean yeah cuz [__] like that cuz I
remember you telling me that story
before and I was like I'm trying to put
myself in that situation if I went in
the room and you were just like laying
there dead I was just like oh my God he
wasn't fat or anything he was he was he
was a slender
guy handsome uh had children out of
wedlock when high school and [__] and
got was knocking up girls and uh as one
does yeah and could tell all these
stories ex Navy
guy and he was uh only like 5 fo
three but he said he had arms like
Popeye he he [__] he didn't work out
but he had big old [__] arms and he
was throwing he owned a hobby shop and
he was one of his jobs he had a hobby
shop and one of the hobby shop was to
make wooden gliders and he was like a
champion glider Builder and thrower and
he owned that hobby shop and there was
something about him throwing gliders
with his hands he was winning
competitions for how far that glider
would go it was just some [__] they did
back in the 50s yeah well they didn't
have video games over they yeah so there
was all kinds of little hobbies that
they did right they didn't have good
porn or anything no he did all he
probably did because he was also had a
photography shop for a while and rumor
was is they took pictures and [__] he
probably had good porn yeah they
probably had I mean good porn for the
time a lot of people don't realize that
how Hightech photography was before back
in the day and one of the things that
dudes that own photography shops would
do is that they would they would hire
girls to come in and they would take
nudes yeah and they had these clubs
where they would trade nudes yeah yeah
and the way my granddad way the stories
I never met him the stories of my
granddad he was probably in a club like
that taking pictures of girls and
trading the pictures with other guys
that's how they because porn was kind of
not legal yeah so they would say stuff
like oh she's like an artist model
artist models so they'd have all these
photographers come and like take
pictures take pictures and then they
would trade pictures with each other and
they were kind of like pinup art but it
was like nude semi nude or whatever they
would just hire models and it was
teenage girls you know uh you know I
don't know if they were underage
probably they didn't have real strict
laws back then
probably nowadays you you got to be at
least 18 to take a nude photos back in
those days it was probably legal to take
nude photos of a girl if she was of the
age of consent or even if it wasn't they
probably wouldn't do anything to you
they probably would think there was
anything about that so you know they
didn't have those laws didn't exist that
mentality didn't exist so who knows
chances are in that
area they were probably high school
girls probably seniors and
[__] yeah Tammy's talking about uh it's
like the Hub said the dogs are looking
around the house for me cuz she's not
home you know she's doing her mom stuff
uh and whenever we're on the phone and
they can hear me they want to put they
wanted to put the phone down by them
yeah that's kind of the thing too it's
like and our our cats wait by the door
like whenever we go out to the store or
whatever we come back and they're both
sitting by the door like waiting for us
to come back um she says we can watch
the Lone Wolf and Cub TV series on
YouTube on a channel called ninja versus
Samurai so yeah so we should watch that
actually that's probably really pretty
good um they're talking about uh cat
claws and stuff like that I got to pee
again so talks more about something and
Chen's wearing an awesome outfit yeah I
have to get that [__] on [__] the
well the pants and the boots are for
Christmas presents yeah a bunch of
Christmas presents I gave them yeah and
then you go ahead and give that a dry
run if that's easy to fing go to the
bathroom
in going to the club she might have to
go to the bathroom some of the [__] we
were trying to do like with corsets and
stuff I got her a
badass uh jump suit that was [__]
skin tight pleather with these big boots
that go up above the knee it would it
look good but the thing is she wanted to
have it looked better with a coret over
it but she go but if I wear this I won't
be able to go to the bathroom I was like
oh
yeah and she said it also kind of like
smashed her boobs together didn't quite
I was I was like man [__] pull those
zippers down let them [__] fly you
know decompress them
man
let me see uh what kind of comments we
got
here yeah Z goes that's nice pants J
yeah they're like uh PVC
pants called ninja versus
Samurai on um
YouTube If you guys don't know what
she's talking
about I got this
Criterion Edition movie collection
called Lone Wolf and
Cub it's katsu Shin or shintaro katsu's
brother stars in it and I believe
shintaro KATU is involved in the [__]
production of
this and it's about an an execution
he's he's he's the shogun's main
executioner he ends up having to go on
the he ends up getting accused of
treason and he has they pass a death
sentence on
him and he and his little son who's only
about this big dressed in his little
[__] Samurai kimono they go on the
run and become
Outlaws and I think it's six movies
that's six movies I think so yeah
they're real good yeah the movies are
awesome real good Japanese movies what's
his son's name um Diago yeah Diago yeah
and that concept of L wolf and CB is
where the concept of Mandalorian
Mandalorian and uh [__] what's his
name [__] uh grou yeah because uh
Diago is basically like
Gru he didn't talk either he just used
his facial expressions he's a super cute
little Japanese boy yeah and he's in a
um keeps him in a baby carriage in a
little roller
yeah and he's wanted and all these uh
Samurai and ninja and assassins they're
all after him and he he cuts them all
down Diago helps though sometimes
because the yeah he's badass that kid
yeah he helps too because the the the
baby carriage is [__] has a bunch of
traps in it blades that fly out of the
kid hits the [__] [__] comes out of
the wheels it's all kinds of crazy [__]
happens kick that yeah he rigs the rigs
the [__] now
that collection of
movies The Packaging of that Criterion
Edition is [__] gorgeous it looks
like Japanese Papyrus from like the yeah
Criterion always does a CR I mean and it
comes with booklets books inside of it
and
photographs it's it's just awesome
quality takes a long time to get through
all six movies they're full length
movies you know a couple hours each and
they're very well made uh they're also
crazy there's crazy parts of them not as
crazy as a Chinese kung fu movie but
some weird [__] happens in them uh they
even
got female samurai or female ninjas
attacking remember was that tattooed
that girl that was all tattooed was she
a ninja or was she a a samurai been a
while since I've seen her she had full
body tattoos you know yeah that was a
good one yeah it was a good one they
these different kind of people they send
people after them with
guns I mean I like that they called one
of the movies baby cart from Hell Baby
cart fromy 2 hell yeah I can't remember
yeah see what
happens in movie
One um now I don't remember [__] what
was lone Wolf's [__] name
[__] I feel like I know this they kept
telling me I think it was just his U his
title was Samurai executioner or
shogun's executioner or something like
that
yeah and he goes crazy after his wife
gets killed and he kills a bunch of
people and he has to go on the run and
he tells Diago says you have to make a
choice I either kill you or you go with
me on this journey through
hell and he puts something on the ground
he puts a sword on the ground and I
think a ball yeah and if he goes for a
ball he's going to kill the boy if he
goes for a sword he's going to [__]
choose he's choosing to go on this
[__] descent into hell which is
that's what the whole movies are about
their descent into [__] insanity and
Hell the little boy [__] crawls out
and [__] goes to the sword says okay
you have chosen you know and that's
where the that's how yeah this is going
to be a hard journey you know we're
going to be a lot of suffering and [__]
you know he's tell you're going to have
to strengthen your mind and little
baby's going huh just like G what yeah
he like I don't even know streng your
mind yeah yeah Tammy said his name is uh
iami that's right iami was the name of
thead a dad
yeah yeah yeah I remember that yeah I
remember that but I didn't remember the
dad's
name if you like that see the movies
because I guarantee you it's yeah we
should watch the TV show though it's
probably my I don't is the TV show the
same cast is it the same is it is it sh
katu's brother does he does he play I
don't know I guess we'll have to find
out yeah and a little boy who who plays
Diago in the movies he's [__] awesome
I love that kid yeah he's adorable yeah
and then and and I I would say his
acting is fantastic yeah and he's not
really acting they just know how to edit
right the editing is [__] great
because the kids's too young to act
they're just filming the kid he's just
this quiet kid dressed up in this
[__] badass little kimono with a
little top knot yeah got cool ass hair
little cut top knot yeah killing and
he's just chilled as [__] he's just
chilled out as [__] yeah we're GNA have
to go kill all these people this and
that you know B his dad's giving him the
whole Lowdown little kid's just chill as
[__] yeah okay that's all right let's go
kill let's go kill all these 300 people
I mean that's just what he knows man
yeah it's not weird to him well they do
the same thing with grou and U
Mandalorian yeah although grou has magic
pow so it's kind of he he can wield the
force right sure but you know what I
mean s said I've been watching movies by
the Russian director Andre Tavi yeah
that's uh he's very famous he only made
five films and three are rated 100% on
Rotten Tomatoes highly recommend his
film stalker you know what I never saw
stalker although I did see a documentary
about the movie stalker so I've been
meaning to watch it for like a really
long time but I just haven't got around
to it yet and said he loved the 70s
version Lone Wolf movies yeah we have
all of them we have the Criterion in
collection now they took all six movies
and compressed them into one movie it
was called Shogun Assassin and it is
[__] insane it does not represent the
[__] series but it is an insane movie
real fun to watch because it doesn't
make any goddamn sense great action
though cuz they took like six movies and
like yeah just smash they're like we're
just going to take all the craziest
scenes from each movie and we're going
to put a all one movie without any
context it's called Shogun Assassin they
played that here in the they played that
here in the United States in the theater
yeah remember being like Drive-In I
remember yeah I remember being in
California seeing the [__] trailer to
show assassin yeah I kind of remember
that too I was pretty little
but why am I Ying already it's 9 o' holy
crap oh it's 9 o' actually we're done at
9:30 yeah yeah yeah we probably got to
leave by 9:30 cuz you know okay the show
at 9:5 they open at 10: when the show at
9:15 s also said nice pants Jenny thank
you very much yeah go ahead and show
them your outfit J got to show them the
outfit yeah here I'll grab the damn oh
the handy cam ready handy cam yeah make
sure I'm all scrunched up go ahead and
fix your [__] go ahead and fix my [__]
fix my [__] hey this belt like Tom made
this I made that
belt haven't been able to wear it for a
while cuz yeah I got two yeah and she's
got this sexy ass little bondage [__]
cooch window turn around let me see
that's what's call I called that the
cooch one and she got the little
straps little boot show the boots I got
those for Christmas back up and getting
that light over
there there's buckles on the back of the
boots yeah can't see enough there you
see the and the boots go over the knee
yeah come back here and the
light yeah the boots go over the knee
yeah they're nice man yeah this is
actually the first time we wearing them
out cuz we haven't really been out since
Christmas yeah now turn
around what are you doing I'm getting
get come here come here trying to get
some good angles
there okay
okay he forgot what streaming service he
on for a
second he forgot what streaming service
he that should be worth a [__] Super
Chat hold on let me get this [__] back
in oh what the hell what the hell now
you've done it why is it doing this
because why is it doing it okay hold on
hold on I see what it's doing I see
it there we go everyone's getting
vertigo oh my god dude well the the uh
yeah the thing got me calm
down all right good okay everything fine
everything fine okay there we go what it
say I don't know well I don't know I
only just that down the original manle
tells the whole story yeah they said the
manga's good matter of fact I think the
Criterion addition there's Snippets of
the manga there that the manga that's
what they're using as like uh some of
the the art in
there I laughed cuz Oracle went we the
camera going around there goes there
come Jeffy I told you I was out there
drying out there shaking tr's trying to
pimp me out I'm trying to pass the
[__] collection plate around Tom's
pimping me out yeah
okay the TV show is different all right
okay I wouldn't mind seeing the TV show
though too yeah I kind of I'd be
interested to see it yeah just like the
TV show of um zatoichi it still gotaro
KATU in it um I don't think it was as
good as the movies but the movies do get
kind of repetitive I mean there's a lot
80 of them are no there's like 26 of
them 26 I think there's 26 of them yeah
some of them better than others and some
of them are kind of repetitive but I
like I like the um Z s movies too yeah
if you guys don't know what that
is it's
about a Japanese back in the Tokugawa I
think believe it's Tokugawa period or E
Edo he's in the Edo period I think um
which has like what 1500s 1600s I think
um I can't
remember it's about a blind
guy who's a
massure and he's a and and he seems he's
not a beggar but he's a mour he runs
around he gives massage
but that's actually his
cover he's a Yakuza sword
fighter he's a good guy he doesn't
really he doesn't he's not trying to get
in any trouble and I don't remember
exactly how he became a sword master I
don't didn't see the first movie I think
his maybe his dad was had a school or
something he had a brother he shows up a
couple times
too but he has this sword and it's
hidden inside of a
Cane so it looks like a walk
stick but he can pull it out and it's
totally straight it's not a
curved Samurai stord it's not
a classic Katana it's straight even
though some of the very early katanas
were straight this one is just like a
thin straight Katana they sell replicas
of it the satui [__] cane swords some
of them things are [__] expensive
they say some of them are actually
battle ready um the expensive ones but
he does all kinds of of [__] with it he
does everything he's kind of like
Daredevil he does it by
sound and
um in the stories he ends up doing [__]
like getting women out of prostitution
because their [__] deadbeat husbands
[__] got into debt and [__] dude
sold her into to the [__] wh house
and he tries to get her out of that it's
those kind of stories or you go he he
makes his way into a town and some
corrupt Samurai [__] pick on
him or and he's got to get even or he
goes into there and a bunch of gamblers
[__] steal his money or try to steal
his money and makes a bunch of [__]
yeah he don't um he don't [__] with
people don't [__] with him first yeah
you got to [__] with him first and will
yeah mess up your whole day and he's a
real good character zigi he played by a
guy named sh KATU shintaro or in English
would be shintaro KATU because they the
last they do last name first in uh
Oriental languages or Asian languages
Eastern
langu and um although in J Japan they
call him
kushin which is kind of like saying Tom
Cruz instead of Thomas Cruz
kushin now he was the interesting dude
himself getting in trouble for cocaine
and [__] drugs he accidentally killed a
guy on [__] scene with a sword well
yeah he got in trouble for that
it was his friend though it was an
accident just there was a real sword and
[__] that dude accidentally cut him
some people said well he must have been
dranken I don't think he was
a um he was a great singer okay he would
uh do Frank Sinatra covers and you you
can find him a good song to listen to of
of shintaro KATU
is one of the theme one of zi's theme
song is called darkness is my Ally and
it's it's on YouTube just look up
Darkness as my Ally shitaro KATU and he
does a [__] great job singing he
could sing he could act he could [__]
pretty good with a sword and he wrote a
lot of the uh of the of the um
zichi basic scripts you know now his
brother I think it might have been his
younger brother played EO in Lone Wolf
and Cub and he was bigger he was a
bigger guy and more imposing than zigi
or um but still just just good dudes
they were making money on making Samurai
flicks man you know be like if Clint
Eastwood had a brother they'd be making
[__] Western flicks you know same
[__] High Desert said I think that kid
in real life the one that played dioro
um got busted for murder all right funny
child stars get in
trouble well I can see how that happens
yeah because you don't really get to
have a normal childhood I don't know if
that's I mean you know that might not be
the same in other cultures but in this
culture for sure yeah it's very rare to
have like a child star that ends up like
Okay and like well adjusted yeah weird
[__] Happ cuz all kind of bad [__] a lot
of happened but I think in our case the
child stardom is happening in [__]
Hollywood in the LA area and that's
already
trouble that's part of it yeah even
adults it's yes so there's bad
influences around him and uh Hollywood
is not a safe place for children I'm
going to say it for that I'm not going
to talk about programs like MP4s or MP3s
or PDF files I'm not going to talk about
the PDF files but uh no Hollywood isn't
safe for
children I mean and that that those
stories go way back to like you know
[__] what was his name Tatum O'Neal
and all that well it goes back to the
earliest days of Hollywood 20s the 30s
yeah they didn't care how old you were
if you wanted to be in those movies you
were going to have to [__] and the
thing about it is that it's bad now but
it's like I think it might have been
worse like back in like the 20s and [__]
yeah cuz no one would have believed it
back then people were more in innocent I
think and people were poorer too yeah
and there wasn't the same cultural
discussion about it that we have
nowadays so it's like if you just had
that done to you then you'd just be like
oh well I guess that's how [__] goes you
know what I mean yeah you can pretty
much you can pretty much if any of those
actresses of and actors I believe with
the Silver Screen [__] went down with
all of them male or female they had to
get
jobs yeah I mean one of the oldest
tricks was is
that some producers trying to [__]
raise money for this movie that he's
going to make and he's got all these
investors and [__] and he takes the
[__] stars to these parties where the
investors are and [__] goes down there
if she puts out to this one investor
he'll put in the $30,000 you know it's
that kind of
[__] yeah they're Crooks they're
grifters they're grifters and they do it
because what are the Alternatives the
alternatives are you go back to the
ghetto in La they don't have any skills
to speak of they're not it's easy to act
I can act I was trained as an actor as
was a kid it it doesn't have anything to
do with your talent there's a lot there
are a lot of talented actors you want
those jobs you're going have to do some
[__] for it that [__] black comic
just came out with it I think it's a
comic came out or or maybe he's a rapper
came out came out and just said yeah all
these [__] Rich dudes all these rich
rappers those dudes all sucked dick to
get those
jobs you said he didn't want to suck
dick Oracle said I have a friend who is
a child actor and she said the problem
is you're scene as valuable and special
until you hit a certain age when you're
no longer cute yeah well they don't know
how cute you're going to be when you hit
adulthood you hit adulthood and you're
you're you're [__] you're not cute
anymore and they're like well you were
at disappoint
but some of them do make it into
adulthood depends on what they look like
yeah yeah um she also said check out
some old yeah Shirley Temple movie you
see that poor child getting groped by
grown men yeah and it wasn't like seen
as weird everybody just thought it was
cute like there was um I remember seeing
clips from like some Shirley Temple
movies where like grown men are like
talking about being in love with her and
stuff like I'm like dude this is
problematic yeah but they did they
thought it was funny but it wasn't funny
that shit's not funny and and it also
they say that commentators are s who
know Hollywood real well are saying that
they are they were filming her in the
same way they fil filmed adult sex
symbols yeah with the same lenses and
the same angles and that there's a lot
of stuff there she was a cute little
girl oh yeah they were making a lot of
money on off of her and she was a good
little
actress man that shit's not real
appropriate it's no but that
inappropriate [__] was in the other
direction they didn't really think of it
they thought it was funny yeah they just
thought it was cute and funny but I was
like that's not really funny in The
Little Rascals or our gang you had all
the little boys [__] hitting on Miss
crab tree yeah remember that I love you
Miss Crabtree and she's just laughing
yeah like okay I mean that's funny when
you look at it that way all these little
boys hitting on the school teacher
writing love letter but they were doing
it the other way around that's what I
mean and it's not quite the same because
like the little boys are like oh they
love their teacher but she wasn't like
reciprocating she was just like oh
whatever they're like little kid she
wasn't you know oh okay I'm going to go
out with Spanky or what you know what I
mean that would be that would be creepy
laughing it off yeah she was just like I
said so had they done it the other way
where she's like I'm going to go out on
a date with buckwhat or whatever yeah
that would have been problematic I think
they thought that flipping it flipping
the
genders I think they just thought that
was funny innocent right like yeah I'm
going to date this little chick here
you're just a full you're like a
beautiful woman and she's yeah yeah cuz
that's how they talk that's how they to
like in the movie like they in the in
her movies they talk to her like that
take serious I think the the average I
think the average person thought it was
a joke and we didn't take it seriously
still though but no in
Hollywood no I think they [__] I
think they probably knew what they they
were probably they were probably going
no no we you know this little chick is
attractive and maybe you know we caning
yeah maybe we can mess around with her a
little bit it's kind of like what
they're that's kind of what they were
saying here have a little bit of this
that's what I mean or they were in they
were implying that yeah like I said
maybe a lot of people that weren't wa
that were watching it like at the
theater maybe they didn't perceive it
that way like they just thought it was
cute or funny or whatever but it's just
kind of like nowadays that [__] does not
fly yeah and it shouldn't it shouldn't
fly I'm not sure it flew back then in
terms of like the people that were in
Hollywood who knew what it meant I think
they actually I'm talking about like in
The Wider culture like cuz I think most
people maybe unless they were [__]
perverts this whole cuz they had
perverts back then
too people get very confused over this
whole 18
thing federal law says you cannot take
photographs of anyone sexual photographs
or if it's if they're nud and sexual you
can't if it's like a nature program and
you have [__] you know what I mean
tribal people uh running around if
they're under 18 you can't take pictures
of
them it wasn't always that way
though a lot of things that have to do
with the age of consent and just because
you can't take pictures of them doesn't
mean you can't have sex with them that
falls on the state some states the age
of consent is 13 in Mississippi it
was I don't know if it still is it pro
it's probably 16 now I would doubt that
yeah Pro it's probably 16 now but
there's weird [__] like you can marry
him at 13 with the [__] parents
consent but that's not
happening you know that's like some [__]
from the [__] early 1900s
maybe uh probably that's when that [__]
sto stopped and then there's um some of
the states have tried to mitigate it and
they with what's called statutory
laws where age of consent might be
16 but you cannot do anything physical
with her if you're like 6 years older or
8 years or 9 years older than she is
only young guys can hit basically is
what they're
saying but that depends on the
state so lot of people get tied up in
the 18 oh like well that teacher got
busted well it has to do with the
[__] State and Most states say if you
a teacher you cannot have anything to do
because that's an authority thing yeah
you can't have anything to do and
generally in most cases if someone has
some kind of authority over you whether
it's your teacher your boss or whatever
it is that's going to be like a power
Dynamic and that's going to introduce
some complication evidently that does
not apply to universities though that
University professors can have sex with
any student well now well because
they're all older MH so you just presume
well they're all adults so it's not like
right I mean people probably would I
don't know I guess it would depend on
the situation people probably look a
scance at depending on the situation but
like I said those are all adult so
that's a different
situation um yeah Tammy said um Shirley
Temple said men were coming on to her in
real life when she was very young
probably true yeah and oh I'd imagine
yeah cuz like I said they've had PDF
files forever and Oracle said yeah she
talked about using her dance training to
escape being getting groped yeah well
guys we're being primed for it by
watching her movies they're saying well
I guess she is a sex symbol yeah so
she's available
and it's just kind they kind of like
they weren't in they weren't in a
society where there were
limits like I said that's why it's a
little irresponsible to be like
portraying children like that a lot of a
lot of the world's like that well I know
but I'm just saying yeah it's just
because some people are going to use
that
as you know
justification in the Middle East most of
those countries do not have anything
like laws like that at all because in
Islam uh one of the Prophet Muhammad's
wife was like eight I think so therefore
if it's good enough for the prophet then
it's good enough for you so it's and I
don't think I don't think there is
anything like age of consent or being
underage in any of those countries I
mean somebody might drop it in the
comment section maybe you're from one of
I I
I if there were it would be if any
country banned
it I would think it might be a country
like Saudi Arabia cuz Saudi Arabia is
really starting to change certain things
about the way that they do I have to ask
sad about that he lives there but um
technically I think as long as the as
the families approve I think you can
marry anybody of any
age if she's
Muslim although a Muslim can marry a
woman of any religion just not the other
way around
uh it have to have have to consult a
Hadith over that probably I'll ask S
what the rules are yeah Oracle said um
Shirley Temple sh signed with um MGM
after leaving 20th Century Fox upon
meeting with Arthur freed from MGM for a
preliminary interview the producer
exposed his genitals to her okay yeah
and Tammy said yeah that's in her
biography yeah yeah so you know Dana
said women had been allowed to drive in
Saudi Arabia for almost 10 years now
yeah that's they changed a bun stuff
they did yeah it's not quite as strict
as it was
was still though that always I don't
know it always like made me really like
watching because I've seen like some of
Shirley Temple's movies and stuff like
that and like watching that makes me
really uncomfortable the same way that
watching like
nowadays like little kid like little kid
beauty pageants like the John B Ramsey
thing that's super creepy too yeah super
[__] creepy okay we're it's about
time yeah we gota get ready yeah we got
to dip out because we're going to go out
to momento Mory this evening it's the
9th anniversary yeah of momento Mory
tonight so I'm glad that you came back
yeah and you could go because if you had
not been back I wasn't going by myself
and it was funny CU I said that last
night and Tom's like what I trust you
I'm like dude it doesn't have anything
to do with that I was just like I didn't
want to drive all that way at night by
myself in case something happened to the
car I didn't want to like be out in the
middle of nowhere and the car broke down
or some [__] like that you know what I
mean so that was the only thing it's
like I wouldn't do anything behind your
back you know that yeah but yeah I just
I I said it's more of a safety issue
it's like I don't want the car breaking
down in like the middle of [__]
Eustace someplace and getting murdered
you know what I'm saying because it's
the middle of the night so yeah but
we're uh yeah so we're going to go and
have some fun with our friends and
hopefully uh everything will be cool
that's I'm looking forward to it
hopefully we have a good crowd tonight
for the ninth anniversary but yeah so
we'll be back on Monday doing a movie
review not sure what movie it's going to
be but we'll figure something out this
week weekend so thanks everybody for
dropping by tonight and hanging out with
us on this Friday night thanks for super
chats and we'll see you guys again on
Monday night good night